hey everybody its charlie you guys
requested a big preview for what's going
on in the north the wars to come so this
is going to be all about what's
happening south of the wall as well as
the more with the white walkers in Jon
Snow and Daenerys we're less than 60
days before Game of Thrones gets here so
there is a new round of the book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video there for the enhanced
editions and I will address the trailer
at the end of this HBO is doing
something a little bit different with
the way they mark it season 7 it's very
similar to what it sounds like with the
site from a couple seasons ago like a
lot of problems in the north that could
go really bad that could go really good
so the most important stuff happening in
the north right now is that the Battle
of the bastards is over they defeated
the Karstarks the umbers and the
Bolton's and they have to decide what to
do with their territory there were a lot
of promises made by Jon Snow and Sansa
they went around collecting support for
their cause you have the free folk house
Mormon house hornwood house mazing in
house Arryn that you have to appease now
so there's a lot of territory to be
spread around if Jon Snow chooses to
give those lands to the people that
supported him in a way from the people
that opposed him then you also have to
remember that the real conflict is the
White Walkers north of the wall but the
more immediate problem is the northern
Lords what he's going to do with those
new lands one of the big changes they
could make from the books is that when
the free folk agreed to help Jon Snow he
promises them the gift but because the
TV show has moved past the book plot we
now have all these new lands that had
been freed up for the lesser houses of
the north and the cadet branches of
House Stark even though characters like
the little bear are very practical she
would probably be as upset as any of the
other northern Lords that supported Jon
Snow if he immediately gave extra land
over here to the free folk the funny
thing about the Battle of the bastards
is that most of the people that lost are
all like right here all the people that
supported Jon Snow are on the other side
of Winterfell so there's all this
disputed land and even someone like
Robert Glover looks like he would be
even more upset it was really hard to
get him to support Jon Snow and usually
conflicts like this or where lesser
houses find their opportunities to raise
their lot in life gain extra territory
raise they're standing in the kingdom
remember all the way back to Aegon's
conquest
that's how house Tyrell took control of
the reach because house Gardner previous
kings of the reach opposed Aegon the
conquerer
once he conquered them he named the
Tyrells Lords of the reach and cast down
their house that was the end of it
Sansa made that promise to Ramsay there
are no more suns out there no one to
take up the Bolton name even if they
leave them intact there's still all this
territory around the lonely Hills in the
dreadfort that belonged to the Bolton's
that now has to be divvied up amongst
other houses but all that really implies
is that just because we have all this
stuff going on with Daenerys down at
Dragonstone we have the White Walkers
north of the wall that politics will not
die in the north even though there's
only seven episodes so that's largely
going to fall on Santa and
Littlefinger's character so this is
where you have the little finger problem
backstabbing and double-dealing because
even though sweet Robin now controls the
Vale little finger controls sweet Robin
in promises must have been made in order
to get their help during the Battle of
the bastards and that probably has
something to do with santa's hand in
marriage we all know that Littlefinger
told Santa that he sees a vision of him
and her sitting on the Iron Throne
ruling over Westeros but that's the
long-term game short-term house Aaron is
going to have to be appeased there's
also the Lords of the Vale as well so
even though they hate the crap out of a
little finger they're going to want
something in exchange for their help and
they also probably don't like free folk
any more than the other Lords of the
north even the ones that supported Jon
Snow
they all remember a stark must be in
Winterfell but really none of that has
anything to do with what's going on with
the free folk we know where we need to
get to everyone needs to unite so they
can take care of the White Walkers when
they come south of the wall manufactured
drama or not Littlefinger is the biggest
[ __ ] in that plan he's made no mention
of White Walkers or having any interest
of what's going on north of the wall or
the free folk he just wants the Iron
Throne which means that you need support
which implies that he's going to parlay
his influence with the sweet Robin and
the power of the Vale with the other
Lords of the north to cause problems for
Jon Snow the
in salsa so right now it seems like most
of John snows plot is going to be tied
up with the larger conflict the White
Walkers in Daenerys in Sansa is going to
get to deal with all these little finger
problems while they're away having all
that fun but you guys can let me know in
the comments how do you think that's
going to be resolved right now it seems
like the only way to solve those
problems is to get rid of Littlefinger
the Lords of the North support John Snow
even if he gave extra territory to the
free folk and they didn't like it they
would probably back his play
they watched what he did during the
Battle of the bastards so they might
complain but he earned their respect
but Littlefinger can tear all that down
when Jon Snow isn't around that is what
he does best he operates in the shadows
so let me know how you think that
Littlefinger is going to try and double
deal and backstab Jon Snow in the
progress that they've made in uniting
the north while they're away with
Daenerys at Dragonstone because it
sounds like a lot of his plot line is
going to be taking place there during
season seven before they get to all the
really fun stuff that's happening north
of the wall the unexpected benefit of
this is that it provides us with another
opportunity for a moment like this she
had with Ramsay when he was eaten by his
hounds now Littlefinger doesn't have
house it's not like he's going to be
carried off and eaten by a bunch of
little birds but let me know in the
comments if you think that Sansa is
going to repeat a moment like this with
Littlefinger eventually there really
aren't a whole lot of options for her
character unless she goes south and
starts dealing with Cersei and all the
things that are happening there and it
just feels like so much of her character
is tied up in what's happening at
Winterfell that most of her plot line is
going to take place there which means
that if she's going to have anything
interesting to do at all
it's going to be in dealing with the
Uniting of the north especially dealing
with what's left in the wake of the
Battle of the bastards and it sounds
like Littlefinger isn't going to stay
too far away from her just because he's
so obsessed with her in taking the Iron
Throne the other big conflict the one
that everyone's really interested in is
what's happening with the White Walkers
north of the wall so it sounds like
that's largely going to be pushed
towards the end of the season because
Jon Snow will have to deal with Daenerys
and there's just so much that you have
to explain it's not like he's going to
walk up on Dragonstone bend
and they'll be best friends forever he's
not the kind of person to bend the knee
overnight and they have no common ground
right now Daenerys has made no mention
of White Walkers you know just like
Littlefinger maybe they've heard about
it but it doesn't sound like something
that she's particularly concerned with
right now she's mostly concerned with
the Iron Throne so you're going to have
to prove to Daenerys that there is a
threat of White Walkers somehow and then
you can start to form a union but Jon
Snow needs that dragon glass from
Dragonstone so each side has something
that the other needs
Daenerys needs the support of the north
and she's going to unite everyone
otherwise that's just another war that
she's going to have to fight in Jon Snow
needs her dragons needs the dragon glass
although the funny thing about this is
that he hasn't made any mention of
dragons I cannot wait to see him react
to the dragons I know everyone's like
hey wait a minute if there's all this
politicking does that mean that is not
going to be that many White Walkers
scenes if everyone's dealing with the
wars that are going on in Westeros
Cersei trying to solidify her hold on
the kingdom Jon Snow trying to solidify
his hold on the north Daenerys trying to
take the Iron Throne
there wouldn't be a season of Game of
Thrones if there wasn't a big action set
piece with White Walkers so I think most
of the major conflicts will be in
Westeros but by the time we get to the
last two episodes we will see a nice big
battle hardhome style with White Walkers
normally I'd say it wouldn't be quite as
big as a hard home episode because that
was such a big watermark in Game of
Thrones history but because they reduced
the episode count and there's so many
more big battles I feel like they want
to come big in heart because there's
only going to be six episodes in season
eight and I don't think they want to
save the best to last I think they just
want to do as much of it as possible
every single episode once they get to
that but I know everybody wants to know
where's the trailer because we're about
60 days out as I'm posting this video we
are definitely going to be getting a
trailer very soon usually when you get
within the two month window is when they
really start dropping stuff now they
have a new promotion called whispers of
Westeros so that could be anything but
it just sounds like bonus content that
they're going to be releasing via email
it could turn out to be terrible like
the site promotion that they did where
they sort of DMing you things where it
was really temporary that bugged out it
totally didn't work they didn't repeat
it when they were promoting
season six so I don't think it's going
to be like that but what they'll
probably do is they'll have the regular
trailers they'll release and then
they'll just be other small promotions
that sort of tease things that are
happening with the different houses
because even though the conflicts have
changed the Alliance's have shifted
people tend to focus really easily on
what's going on with House Lannister
House Stark House Targaryen so just
expect a lot of the promotion's to be
centered around houses eventually and
what's going on with the main factions
well leave all your requests for Game of
Thrones bonus videos what will happen is
is once we get some actual footage most
of my videos will focus on the specifics
of what's going on during season seven
it's still a little bit of speculation
right now but we do have a pretty good
idea of where things are headed based on
what's happened before so leave all your
requests for things that you want me to
do videos about but I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Brock Gordon please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for more you can click here for
buy Arya Stark preview and you can click
here for all my other season 7 promo
videos thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight